I want to switch gears for a bit talk
about uh
cars bikes that kind of stuff because
there's not many people out there that I
can have these sorts of conversations
with it's so weird to to me today as an
adult because I remember sitting at the
bus stop as a broke 15 16 year old
looking at like nice cars to drive by
waiting to catch the bus to go to work
thinking to myself you know that's going
to be me driving that car one day and
today as an adult there's not a lot of
guys that like cars for some reason I
don't get I mean there's very small
Niche communities and they'll throw all
kinds of money at it you've got
um how many supercars you have I think
you said the other day something like
two million dollars worth of cars
sitting in your front driveway yeah two
million dollars worth of cars and it's
actually interesting you say that
because I was exactly the same when I
used to see fast cars when I was young
it used to ruin my day it used to make
me angry yeah me too I'd be walking to
college and I'd see a Ferrari and I'd be
like how does he have 300 grand for a
car I haven't got 30 dollars in my
pocket that's all my money in the world
like yeah I felt like there was a whole
reality to The Matrix that I was missing
there's something there's some kind of
hack because even even then I age 15 I
remember this story very specifically
I'm walking to college me and three my
friends we see a Ferrari I look it up I
find how much it costs and and even then
I'm saying to my my mum when I got home
if you work a good job like how much do
you make a month she's like yeah maybe
three thousand four thousand I'm like
that still won't buy that car like how
did this guy get that car it didn't make
sense in my mind yeah and there's a
whole reality to The Matrix that
bothered me for a long time and I think
that's one of the that's one of the the
key elements to things like success in
cars and stuff if you really want it
you'll find a way to get it if you don't
really want it you're not an excuse yeah
you're thinking excuse I think a lot of
the reason people don't like cars is
well they'd love cars if they could buy
one
but they'd rather pretend they don't
like them because they don't believe
they're ever gonna be able to afford one
there's a there's a real loser mindset
that shows up a lot I noticed like
there's this car club that I'm a member
of and we go for these drives right we
always have these organized drives we
meet up in the morning we go for a drive
right so there's like can be anywhere
from 50 to 85 exotic supercars you know
like even like M cars AMG cars stuff
like that and we'll go and meet we'll
have lunch and there's always like
people coming out to look at the cars in
the parking lot I remember sitting in my
car one time and there was this Mom with
her two or three young boys that are
walking around they're like what do
these guys do where do they get these
cars from her she's like oh these are
just rich people showing off you don't
want to be like this sort of thing and
they send the wrong messaging and
like it really bugs me that's that's
literally one of the few things that
irked me is when I hear people say just
quit it's not worth competing just quit
and you know what that's fine because in
life there's there's there's people that
will compete and there's people that
will quit and are just you know more or
less cogs in the wheel
um your passion for cars started when
you were younger I mean you see these
things you see a Ferrari
um I saw a story that you put out once
on your motorcycles because you're in a
bikes at once you had a uh Gixxer you
had a GSXR was it 750 600 I had I had a
600 and then I had a CBR 600 as well and
then I had a Fire Blade I loved bikes
for a very long time because uh yeah
it's cheap speed isn't it I had four of
them yeah yeah there you go so you
understand yeah if you want if you want
real performance they're cheap speed but
yeah unfortunately they come with the
the danger involved I had two bad bike
accidents and um I kind of retired from
bikes when I saw everybody when you
stopped riding them ah so I I was riding
illegally for a while I was riding at 17
and in the law on England is you can't
ride a super bike till you're 21. so at
17 you can have a super bike but it has
to be restricted so I I paid I bought a
bike this is a really long story I'll
make it very very short I had this job I
was an I.T technician at high school I
came out high school and I was I came
back into the same school fixing the
computers and I started uh
[ __ ] one of the students so I got
fired but even though she was 16 I was
17 but because I was a member of Staff
she's a student blah blah so they fired
me and when they and when they fired me
they paid me to the end of my contract
basically and I had this this little bit
of money and I bought a bike I paid to
have it restricted and then I took the
restrictor out myself so at 17 I'm
burning around on this 200 mile per hour
Superbike and everything was good for a
while until some woman who wasn't paying
attention pulls out on me and just takes
me completely out of the game and and
you know you know what the thing is I
remember I remember
I was going about 90 and I got down to
about 70 before I hit her car she pulled
out right in front of me the thing
there's the thing is crazy I saw her
look at me you know when you ride a bike
you watch people's faces yeah
I'm driving I see her come up to the
junction I see her look directly at me
she pulls out anyway and she just pulls
straight out I couldn't believe it and
um I hit the side of her car blah blah
I wasn't asleep or anything I I woke up
I went right over it right over it and I
went back my back and I was winded but I
was awake and I got up
um and I remember this is what put me
off bikes the most when I walked back
over to her car she's still sitting in
the car and she had the most stupid look
on her because it was shock for her she
didn't know what happened but the
expression on her face is what annoyed
me the most I can't even replicate just
just complete just like
like a [ __ ] she didn't know what
happened and I thought is this as great
as I am is this how I'm gonna die like
she like this is a complete idiot it was
crazy and then from there I came to
almost the same conclusion when I was 30
I mean I I never had an accident like
that I had two two close calls
um and I was I was fast enough thing
like I remember I got that thing up to
redline six gear I think it was a ZX7 it
was indicating over 300 on the speedo
you don't look down for very long
because you're even on the highway like
things moving by you really quick
um but that was great great times I mean
I I mean I always tell guys like I
always think that a good motorcycle is a
rite of passage for a man because
they're very very difficult to control
and they're so powerful and the barrier
to entry is so low because any Muppet
can go out there and spend six seven
eight thousand dollars or something
that'll do you know a good 300
kilometers an hour yep yeah they're
they're amazing fun they're great fun
and it's just the other people on the
road and I feel like eventually if you
ride them forever and you ride them the
way
up at some point the way that you were
riding yeah eventually something's going
to catch you and I I you know that's
what happens you get comfortable you get
confident you get comfortable you're
anonymous you've got the mask on you're
doing wheelies you're going faster in
and out of cars you're drawing like
eventually sooner or later or life's
gonna check you yeah then are you gonna
life checked me and I'm still here but I
know some guys that checked and never
woke up again so it gets to that point
where it's like you know and I feel
safer with my cars I feel a lot safer
with the cars if you had a son would you
let him ride a motorcycle that's a very
good question and I don't know because
it was a big part of my life and I loved
it and I think it's maybe a better car
driver and I like what I did but then
also I think of some of the stuff I did
and I'm like
so I don't know I don't know if I let my
son ride a bike that's a very good
question I'd hate to think I've
sheltered him in any way yeah but um I
also know some I had too many calls too
many close calls man so I don't know
there's something I have to think about
so supercars
um you're basically in a coffin I mean
you're in a cage it's a lot it's a hell
a lot safer me if you go off the road
the toll you pay is going to be a lot
lower if something happens anyway
because you got airbags and everything
now today
um what do you have in the in the drive
you've got a 720 an Aston yeah so I've
gone through a list of what you're
sitting on okay so I've got the new 911
992 the Porsche the brand new one I've
got the uh Aston Martin Vanquish s
ultimate which is only 175 in the world
I've got
um uh Lamborghini Huracan I've got
McLaren 720s I've got an M5 competition
I've got S63 AMG I've gone x6m
uh I've got a phantom I think that's it
I think that's it maybe I've missed one
but I think that's so yeah I mean you're
close to 10 10 cars there
um
what's a phantom is that a two-door or a
four-door uh my one is a four-door
four-door okay
um let me ask you about the McLaren
because I drove for the 2018 when it
first came out I mean I I picked up my
R8 and I dropped it off at the
dealership to get software tuning on the
motor and they just pdi'd a 720s and I
was asking the dealer about and he goes
yeah if you want to take it out you know
go for a spin I was I was blown away
like that is going to be my next car
you've had that car for about a year now
yeah those okay so McLarens are
basically like the crazy girl you
shouldn't be going out with
they're beautiful but they're trouble
like you always I always and it's not
just me everyone I know you have little
warning lights engine lights stupid
lights for no reason
but that that's always a problem with
reliability and has it been in the shot
much like do you have a McLaren
dealership in Bucharest or do you have
to ship it out I got ship it to Germany
bro you have to ship it for service yeah
three three countries away and those
warning lights come on out often yeah I
mean I've developed a little system
anyone who's out here with a McLaren
will know exactly what I'm talking about
but if you get in the car and you press
the start button without holding the
break it turns the computer on first and
then I wait and then I wait 10 seconds
for the car the computer to turn on and
then I start the car and that actually
avoids most of the problems and I will
get a warning like maybe twice a year
and it's a warning light for no reason
yeah it doesn't affect the performance
of the car it just annoys me so I have
to sip into Germany get rid of it but
that car is incredibly fast yeah it's
incredible it will smoke a Lamborghini
it will it will kill a Lamborghini it
will kill an R1 I've raced everything
you can think of it Just Smokes
everything but only if it grips this is
the one more thing with it if it's a
little bit wet or it's not quite hot
outside because it's 720 horses to the
rear wheel rear wheels you're just gonna
you're just gonna slide all over the
place you have to make sure you have
grip before you play with it it's
actually a lot more than that they throw
them on the dyno and they found out that
McLaren's been lying about the power
output on the motor uh which doesn't
surprise you but I mean it's it's
literally as fast as the um
uh Holy Trinity of hypercars so
basically the P1 the LaFerrari the 918.
I was actually in
um the UK a couple years ago in the
spring at bruntingthorpe um there was an
event that somebody put together with
the Holy Trinity of hypercars and
um it was a 200 mile an hour challenge
so we had to drive these cars well not
had to like it was a [ __ ] liability
or anything but we had the opportunity
to drive these cars down the airstrip
and the only car that that had enough
power to punch through 200 in a headwind
would the length of the runway was the
LaFerrari so everything below that there
was an Aventador SVD SV a couple other
McLarens a few Porsche Porsche Turbo s's
um another Lambo something other I can't
remember what the hell it was but the P1
actually caught fire that day the guy
that lent the cars McLaren it caught
fire and I didn't get my chance to drive
that car down the strip but I took the
LaFerrari down and that thing was like
normal cars would you floor it on the
highway for those of you that aren't
like if you get in a regular car like a
Honda you know a Honda or something like
that and you get behind you put your
foot down it'll build up a little bit of
speed but when you get into a proper
powerful like 700 plus horsepower car
that's got aerodynamics and it's built
right it just except like it doesn't
stop pulling yep like you're sitting
there doing 180 190 195 and you're
looking at the speed I was like that
just doesn't stop you'll pull all the
way at the top yeah it's like your
limitation is the amount of road that
you have or if there's any cars in front
of you and that's How brave you are
exactly yeah and that's fun the seven
yeah the 720 will pull all the way to
300 kilometers an hour without you yeah
without even a break and the power in
the 720 is amazing but this is the one
thing I'll say about it is that uh I'd
never recommend it to someone as their
first Supercar because of the headache
and because of how dangerous it is it a
McLaren will let you crash so like for
example my my Lamborghini Huracan is so
well built it's so easy to drive it's
four-wheel drive if you don't if you
keep it out of race a girl could drive
it like yeah it's like the Honda Civic
of super cars they're very reliable too
it's easy very reliable it's easy it's
beautiful makes noise it ticks every box
but and off the line except for the
doors yeah yeah yeah it's missing the
doors exactly that's true but off the
line it can even beat the McLaren
because it's got that four wheel drive
system but once once you're rolling if
it's a rolling start from let's say 20
miles an hour the McLaren will just kill
it destroy it that car is so fast it's
unbelievable have you have you had any
mechanical issues with the 720
and they say something's wrong and
nothing's wrong and they reset it and
that's it and then um my huracan's been
perfect my Porsche Porsche's Porsche
isn't it the thing is with Porsche is
that they're such great cars and there's
such value for money but no one cares
yeah no one cares bro you can be in a
992 Turbo S brand new one it's nothing
you park that next to a Lambo or a
McLaren it's invisible yeah it is true
you know it's a shame about them because
I like them as cars but they just don't
have that factor of that show-off Factor
you know have you ever driven one on a
track I don't like the 911s because the
engine's so far back I mean if you don't
get your braking out of the way before
you come into a Bend it's going to
pendulum around you and it throws you
off the track and you're in the rhubarb
before you know it are the new ones more
balanced in the sense or yeah because
the motor mounts kind of shift the
weight a little bit yeah it does it does
certainly feel better than new one but
the the best handling car I have of all
of them is the Huracan super surprises
me the hurricane if I were to race the
720 in a Huracan on a really windy track
the hurricane might take it really grips
like anything not like nothing I don't
know what I don't know what they've done
to that car but it really is incredible
and this is the thing people say to me
why do you have so many cars and it's
like there's so many subtle differences
in all of them this is my justification
my mom is like what are you doing
another car I'm like no but they're
different you know they're all a little
bit different it's like having a blonde
and a brunette you want to mix it up a
little bit so it keeps driving fun when
I have all these cars and yeah they're
expensive and you know but it's a whole
business something I enjoy to do and
since I've retired from fighting I have
to find one one way to get some
adrenaline and McLaren 720 will do it so
yeah it'll definitely wake you up
um I was gonna ask you about the uh the
car situation so the problem with super
cars that I find especially McLarens
right like the like the mp412c yeah I
did a video on my channel a long time
ago around 2015 or so when 12C it just
come out I think was 20 2013 it just
come out and a friend of mine had one we
took it out for dry I have brilliant car
300 350 000 Canadian dollars I think it
costs them maybe a little bit more you
can buy those now for 120 Grand Canadian
yep they like they sink like a rock and
most of the cars you have like a regular
Huracan it's not limited production it's
not a performante 720 it's not an LT for
example
um they don't hold their value very well
so my question to you is why have seven
or eight supercars a tank in value why
not limit it down to three or four that
are more limited production like a GT2
RS or like an LT version of a McLaren or
like a performante version of a Huracan
no it makes a lot of sense makes a lot
of sense so with all my cars there's
there's always some kind of scenario
where I end up getting a fantastic deal
so I can even tell you the story behind
my
my McLaren so I have all my cars are
British plated even though I live in
Romania
so my my wheels on the wrong side so uh
which annoys everyone but me I'm used to
it so it doesn't bother me so all my
cars are British plated and one of the
reasons for that is is because I have a
very good friend who works recovery for
a leasing company
so uh people lease these cars and they
can't afford them anymore and then the
leasing company takes them back and then
at least the company wants to get rid of
them so I'll give you an example with my
McLaren my McLaren was bought brand new
for 280 000 pounds so that's like 350
000 Euro
uh 4 000 miles later I got it for 175
000 pounds so I saved 105 000 pounds for
3 000 miles
so it was like a leaser Finance reap
repossession they just couldn't afford
it up and then they're looking for
someone who has to cash sitting around
which is rare not many people have 170
Grand cash but no I had it so I I said
you can I saved so much money so with a
lot of my cars I saved a lot of money I
mean the Aspen will keep money because
it's limited production yeah um so I
find ways to save money on them and also
what I find is not that this justifies
my stupid habit at all but because I
have so many I don't really put many
miles on them because I still need to
drive or even across a year even if I
drive every day because I have nine you
know they don't really put too much
mileage on them Etc et cetera so I mean
I know I'm always going to lose some
money on them but I I really don't
approach them that way I buy them and I
enjoy them I don't think about resale
values and stuff I'm just like whatever
it is what it is as soon as in my mind
the money's gone whatever I get for it
when I sell it good but in my mind the
money's gone and I just buy it to enjoy
it and you you live once man I want to
die with no money in my pocket I'm not
really one of them
family Legacy kind of people I was
raised poor and I'm happy I was raised
poor and I want my sons to be raised
poor so all them every penny I get I'm
gonna blow so you better give it to me
and I'm gonna spend it like my dad died
with 12 and I'm gonna die with 11 and
that I'm happy to go that way so that's
how it's going to be what do you think
of the new 720 LT what is it 765. yeah
have you seen the specs on that yeah bro
okay even the seven even the 720 is I
don't think I don't feel like I've
mastered it yet so I don't need to buy a
new one yet I feel like there's still
more in that car I've not yet
experienced it's so fast so maybe I mean
maybe maybe you know one will get
repossessed they'll offer it to me a
little bit cheap and we'll see what
happens we'll see hold on to that hey
guys I really hope that you enjoyed that
short clip if you did consider
supporting the creation of content by
checking out my supplement line pinned
in the top comment below of this video
in the comments there's a link to the
unpluggedalpha.com forward slash shop
when you click through you'll be able to
land over here and the entire lineup up
is broken down by category that it
performs best in estrogen metabolism fat
burning your foundational Essentials for
health immune Health performance and
testosterone support if you check out
with coupon code Alpha 10 you'll get 10
off on your first order there's also the
option to use the Subscribe and save
model or regular shipments will be sent
over to you on a regular basis and that
gives you a little bit of a discount and
your supplement facts are always broken
down over here thanks for watching I
hope you guys have an awesome day and
again check out that link it's pinned in
the top comment below in this video
peace out